[music] the
bulk of even those who had other
views,
they have mobilized today and
already want to be protected so that they
stay alive in their homes and understand
that
we have a different system and, in general,
they don’t want a different life behind the Iron Curtain
they
[music]
I told my relative in Russia mine
when my spirit came who came I’m ready
with my teeth hands my husband in the same way my
children said in the same way
that I was in this second world war
they said not an inch of land we would not give up
our house in the same way and  that’s all, and my
friend’s entourage asked me
what jyj more if they come, well,
like you need to bend, but in your
environment someone is happy that Russia has entered
our territory, you answered
my entourage there are none, and even if they
exist, then with me  they don't dare and longing
fighting spirit it only gets stronger 5
[music]